thank you thank you you all know that I  am the architect of this neighborhood  but what you don't know is God I am not  supposed to tell you this but oh what  the heck this is actually the very first  neighborhood that I have ever designed I  have been an apprentice for over 200  years and my boss has finally given me  my first solo project for everybody yes  and you deserve a perfect world because  every single one of you is a good person  that's it for me back to you too honey  and I would just like to quickly say if  any of you would like to play tennis  tonight we have 36 regulation grass  tennis courts all right why did she  still have that British accent right no  one else here has an accent she's  choosing to have that access just a  beautiful utterly perfect cartoon okay  it's time to go home wait wait I just  have to go upstairs real quick and steal  a bunch of gold stuff okay don't do that  you